How do we define a circle Previously we have seen what a
center is We have also seen that
a circle is made up of points which are
all equidistant from the center
so let's try to form the definition of a
circle The first thing we should notice is  That it
is a set of all points
second how are the points on the circle
related to this point in the center yes they are
equidistant from that point
so we can say that a circle is a set of all
points equidistant from a point
remember it says  All points equidistant
from a point Let's look at another definition
and trust me This one's more
interesting to know The other definition we need to understand the term locus This
word sounds
familiar to the word locus Which looks something like this And that's why I never even
Tried to Understand What It Means
Till I Started Teaching Anyway
The Concept Is Really Simple A locus
is a word used to represent a set of
all points that is a
locus all the points should share
some common property so if this is the center
of the circle  The circle is a locus of points
equidistant from the center that is the common
property all those points share they are all equidistant
from one
point If I draw 1000 random points which are
not related to each other in any way they cannot be called a locus Let's understand
Another Example of a Locus Did you know that even
a line can be defined as a locus of
points Consider two
points a and b we need to
mark points which are equidistant
from the points a and b and lie on the same
plane let this be our  First point This
point is equidistant from points a and
b This is another point like that And we continue to
mark all such points and
guess what all these points together will form a
straight
line So how can we define a line It can be
defined as a  Locus of points on a
plane equidistant from two points So
a locus is the set of all points that share a
common
[music]
property